es ist fast schon ein wenig gespenstisch
ihr jetzt in ruhe den letzten
kriegstagen erhalten hier die schreie
und das stöhnen der vielen verletzten
soldaten durch die katakomben
die junge schwesternschülerinnen doris
opa kümmert sich um diese männer so gut
sehen kann
es fehlt nämlich nicht nur an
betäubungsmitteln wie morphium
es sind auch kaum noch ärzte da mit
einer benzingetriebenen säge amputiert
sie beine versorgt notdürftig kopf und
bauch schüsse fielen aber kann sie nicht
mehr helfen
die hygienischen bedingungen im
improvisierten lazaretts sind
katastrophal
doris bober kann weder sich noch die
verletzten waschen die wasserleitungen
kaputt der hunger riesengroß als doris
bober am zwanzigster april eher zufällig
im keller der reichskanzler adolf hitler
sieht ist nicht mehr viel übrig von der
faszination führer
sie hofft nur noch auf eines kriegen wir
jetzt vielleicht etwas zu essen
und am 20 april war ich im
luftschutzkeller in der reichskanzlei
unten
und der kam er hitler zu uns rein das
war sein letzter geburtstag
wir waren alle verdattert er daher sehr
schlecht als und wir kriegen dann kam
auf uns zu und dankte uns das erfüllen
der ein dickes nicht weit
dann ging er wieder in die hand
dafür war schon ein paar manche und gibt
jetzt eine situation für uns kommst du
den tag
ja er hat doch geburtstag oder der essen
gefühle in uns und um uns hat gebe ihm
kraft und gesundheit und schütze in vor
jeder gefahr
das übrige wollen wir schon tun die rede
von dr system die potters für das nicht
gehört dann zu erkennen gibt es kein
hamburger was hast du was weiß ich auch
nicht so genau
sollte mich heute hier melden bis es
sicher besser auf
nichtwissen schwester
kein gastieren wir tun was wir können
es tut mir leid doch irgendwann trennen
morgen sind die russen ihr spätestens
lieferwagen first hitler gesehen
die andere schwester ja ich habe angst
als reiter und
märz statt
die sp hatte
ganz gut
seit gestern sind die russen mir nein
nein sie haben nichts getan aber
sie geben sich wortkarg
pass bloß auf dass du bald wieder gesund
was papa
da konnte ich mich aber zu sagen was er
nicht stimmt aber ich darf nur mit ihm
sprechen wenn ich ihnen wie schwester
eintracht rheine
danach war schluss wird dann den brauch
die sorge um ihre mutter lässt doris
bürger nicht los es bleibt mir nichts
anderes übrig sie muss sich trotz der
großen gefahr allein auf die suche
machen
ich denke meine mutter war
wir sind hier polizeilich nicht gemeldet
der keller ist ausschließlich für aus
für roller verschwenden situation
ich bin vor vier tagen den russen
verstarb seit drei tagen die zeuge
gestern und sie warum ich jetzt nicht zu
meiner mutter lassen
ich habe meiner vorschriften und ob ich
es auch also wenn sie jetzt nicht
reinlassen
denn passiert weil ich bin bald einige
male ich bin nur im dienst
das ich liegt er aber
ich habe schon gedacht die sich nie
wieder die russen
die ersten mal ganz in ordnung ist in
einem primitiven gehen lassen
danach
diese nachgekommen sind die
die verwundeten erschossen
wir haben gehofft wie die vandalen
verdienen war keine frau sicher
war dir du bist du nicht passiert hätte
chemnitzer fc
duisburger kann sie zunächst weiter von
den rotarmisten versteckt
muss aber später als trümmerfrau die
leichten der schlacht um berlin werden
im jahre 1948 wird sie mutterland worte
und kümmert sich in der fürsorge stelle
des berliner senats und sozial schwache